This is the Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In this episode, we're going to talk about near misses, almost and not quite. First, we're going to talk about research that shows that coming close to winning something can really affect your drive and motivation. You want to build that thing in, that, hey, you're almost there. Then my friend Daniel Pink will join us for a round of stop-watch signs. He's going to explain how the psychology of getting close to a goal can help charities raise more money. Why do people give?
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。在本期节目中，我们将讨论“差点成功”、遗憾落败和功亏一篑。首先，我们要聊聊一项研究：该研究表明，接近赢得某样东西会极大地激发你的驱动力和积极性。你会想要树立这样一种信念，即，嘿，你就要成功了。接着，我的朋友丹尼尔·平克将加入我们，进行新一轮的“秒表科学”环节。他将解释目标达成过程中的心理学如何帮助慈善机构筹集更多资金。人们为什么会捐款？
People give not because they want to be altruistic, but because they want to be effective. Finally, we last sing our songwriter, Casey Mus Musgraves to put on an imaginary lab coat and join us for a game of mad scientist. This is my lab coat. Have rhinestones on it? We lost her to explain a song from her album Pageant Material and we learned what world piece has to do with swimsuits. Okay, near Mrs. Monica Wadwa is a professor at the NCAD Business School in Singapore.
人们捐款不是因为他们想表现得无私，而是因为他们想发挥作用。最后，我们请来了我们的词曲作者凯茜·马斯格雷夫斯，让她穿上想象中的实验白大褂，和我们一起玩“疯狂科学家”的游戏。这是我的实验白大褂。上面有水钻吗？我们请她解释她专辑《选美标准》中的一首歌，并了解了世界和平与泳衣有什么关系。好的，关于差点成功。莫妮卡·瓦德瓦是新加坡欧洲工商管理学院的市场营销教授。
She studies marketing and recently in her research, she hit upon a strange but promising way to change how consumers behave. It's funny because this came from one of my childhood experiences actually. To understand this idea, let's travel back in time to Monica's childhood. I was born in Bratapin, India, in Delhi. Like many 13-year-olds, Monica had a craze. Now her craze was somewhat unusual. It was buying lottery tickets.
她研究市场营销，最近在她的研究中，她偶然发现了一种奇怪但很有前景的方法，可以改变消费者的行为。这很有趣，因为这实际上源于我童年的一次经历。为了理解这个想法，让我们时光倒流，回到莫妮卡的童年。我出生在印度德里附近的普拉塔普加。像许多13岁的孩子一样，莫妮卡曾有一种狂热。现在她的这种狂热有点不寻常。那就是买彩票。
As a child, I kind of wanted to have tons of money, right? So, and I was lazy. So, lottery tickets was my answer to good life. She played the lottery constantly. And remember those days we could buy lottery tickets. They were used to be stalls. You could just go get a lottery ticket for, I remember paying ten rupees for it at that time. And you buy this lottery ticket and if you get like a certain set of numbers,
小时候，我挺想拥有成吨的钱的，对吧？所以，而且我很懒。因此，买彩票就是我对美好生活的答案。她经常买彩票。还记得那些日子里我们可以买彩票。以前有那种小摊。你随时可以去买一张彩票，我记得当时花十卢比买的。你买了这张彩票，如果你中了某一组数字，
if you get all of that correct, you could get a jackpot. How many digits did it have? I think it was six. So you have to get the lottery sort of requires you to match all six digits to win the prize. Yes. There was a problem, though. Her dad worried that her passion for the lottery was
如果你把这些全猜对，你就能赢得头奖。它有多少位数？我想是六位。所以你必须——买彩票需要你对中全部六位数字才能赢得奖品。是的。不过有个问题。她爸爸担心她对彩票的痴迷
distracting her from her schoolwork. A big exam was coming up, and he needed her to focus. Not to mention, her habit was casting him a ton of money, but Monica kept buying lottery tickets until one day. Then I insisted on getting more, he's like no more, that's it. You know, I don't know about you becoming a millionaire, I'm definitely going to get bankrupt. So they worked out a deal. Her dad would allow her to buy one last lottery ticket before the big exam, which she did. And then she waited for the results.
分散了她的学业。一项大考即将来临，他需要她集中精力。更不用说，她的习惯花了他一大笔钱，但莫妮卡一直买彩票，直到有一天。然后我坚持要买更多，他说没门，就这样了。你知道的，我不知道你会不会成为百万富翁，但我肯定会破产。于是他们达成了一项协议。在大考之前，她爸爸允许她买最后一张彩票，她照做了。然后她等待着结果。
The results would come in a particular newspaper. So describe to me exactly what happened when that paper arrived that morning. Do you remember anything about the day at all? I don't remember the exact thing. I just remember the emotions. You know, I remember, I was supremely excited. You know, you're like kind of a truancy. Did I win it? Did I get it? In looking at the first yes it matched, second yes it matched, third yes it matched. And I'm just there. I am going
结果会刊登在某份报纸上。所以，请确切地告诉我那天早晨那份报纸送达时发生了什么。你对那天还有任何记忆吗？我不记得具体的事情了。我只记得那些情绪。你知道的，我记得，我当时兴奋极了。你知道的，你就像是有点逃学的心态。我赢了吗？我中了么？看着第一个，是的，对了；第二个，是的，对了；第三个，是的，对了。我简直就在那里。我只要
to be a millionaire in just about one second, right? Foot one matched. And then the fifth. Dammit, it did not. She lost. I got my 10 rupees back. But the thing is, in that moment, 13-year-old Monica's emotions were not what you might expect. She was actually happy. I think I was feeling excited
再过大约一秒钟就要成为百万富翁了，对吧？第四个中了。然后是第五个。该死，没中。她输了。我拿回了我的10卢比。但问题是，在那一刻，13岁的莫妮卡的反应并不像你想象的那样。她其实很高兴。我想我当时感到兴奋
of an after. I was like, oh, hey, I almost got it. And so your reaction when you got 4 out of 6, you were not dejected, you were not, oh my god, that was so close, I could have been so rich, and now I just get my 10 rupees back. It was kind of mixed feeling, you know, it was like, yes, there was a little bit of dejection, but maybe it's just me, but there was a lot more excitement. I was an almost winner. You know, I was almost there. I got it. How many people actually get almost there?
之后也是。我当时想，哦，嘿，我差点就中了。所以当你中了6个中的4个时，你的反应不是沮丧，你不是在想，天哪，太可惜了，我本可以这么富有，而现在我只拿回了10卢比。这是一种有点复杂的感情，你知道的，就好像，是的，有一点沮丧，但也许只是我这样，不过有更多的兴奋。我是一个差一点儿的赢家。你知道的，我差点就成功了。我拿到了。到底有多少人能差点成功呢？
And this is where she surprised her dad and maybe even herself. She didn't slack off before the exam. I actually fucked Hada. Really, I remember I was very excited for the exam because I's best recollection of her performance in the exam. Monica realized later that after she had nearly won the lottery, she had a strong left over urge to succeed, to do well at something, anything. Just the desire to get something. And that's something happened to be the exam that it last on to, I guess.
正是在这里，她给了她爸爸一个惊喜，甚至可能连她自己都感到意外。她在考试前并没有偷懒。我其实很——。真的，我记得我当时对考试非常兴奋，因为我——她对自己在考试中表现的最佳回忆。莫妮卡后来意识到，在差一点赢得彩票之后，她有一种强烈残留的渴望，想要成功，想要在某事上做得很好，任何事都行。仅仅是想得到什么的渴望。而那个“某事”恰好成了她抓住不放的考试，我猜。
Fast forward a couple decades, and this childhood experience has now become the focus of Monica's academic research and marketing. When you get closer to a reward, your motivation intensifies as you approach the reward. But when you miss it, you have this intensified motivational state, which is not satisfied now. And our theory was that this intensified, but not satisfied motivation will spill over and will make you seek other unrelated rewards now. She and her colleagues recently tested this theory in a number of ways. In one experiment, they recruited people to play a video game. We designed a game where they had to uncover some tiles and if they uncovered eighth diamonds they could win a reward. By design some people clearly won the game, some clearly lost and then others. They missed
快进几十年，这段童年的经历现在成为了莫妮卡在市场营销学方面学术研究的焦点。当你更接近奖励时，随着你接近奖励，你的动机就会增强。但当你错过它时，你就会处于这种增强的动机状态，而这种状态现在没有得到满足。我们的理论是，这种增强但未得到满足的动机将会溢出，并促使你现在去寻求其他不相关的奖励。她和她的同事最近通过多种方式测试了这一理论。在一个实验中，他们招募人们玩一款电子游戏。我们设计了一个游戏，他们必须揭开一些方块，如果他们揭开八颗钻石，他们就能赢得奖励。按照设计，有些人明显赢得了游戏，有些人明显输了，然后还有其他人。他们错过了
the reward just by one diamond. Monica wanted to know about that last group's almost win. Would that motivate them to seek another reward, so we kind of secretly measured how much time, for example, it takes them to reach another reward, like a chocolate bar, which they could collect from another booth. People who nearly one, they walked much faster to get that chocolate. They were much more eager to get the second unrelated reward as compared to those who won or those who clearly lost.
奖励仅仅差一颗钻石。莫妮卡想了解最后一组“差点赢”的人。那会促使他们去寻求另一个奖励吗？所以我们暗中测量了，例如，他们花多长时间去获得另一个奖励，比如一根巧克力棒，他们可以从另一个摊位领取。那些差点赢的人，他们为了得到那块巧克力走得快得多。与那些赢了的人或明显输了的人相比，他们更渴望获得第二个不相关的奖励。
You actually had a chocolate bar at another station and you actually measured how fast people took to walk to that second station. Yes. And your theory is that people were walking faster in some ways because they had nearly missed the first reward and that put them in a state where they basically said my desire for the next reward is even higher. Right. Turns out the video game's new winners also salivated more when they stared at money, which I had to ask about. What's the connection between salivation and watching money?
你在另一个站点准备了一根巧克力棒，你实际上测量了人们走到第二个站点花的速度。是的。而你的理论是，人们走得更快，在某种程度上是因为他们差点错过第一个奖励，这让他们处于这样一种状态：他们基本上说，我对下一个奖励的渴望甚至更高。没错。事实证明，电子游戏的新赢家在盯着金钱时也会分泌更多唾液，我不得不问一下。分泌唾液和看着金钱之间有什么联系？
You're not going to eat the money. That is to event to saliv celebration has been shown to be a measure of desire. So when you desire something you celebrate more. In a second experiment the researchers gave people lottery tickets outside a shopping mall. Again the idea was that some people would win, some people would lose and some would be near winners. The researchers then measured how much the near winners spent once they entered the mall. They spent a lot more than those who clearly near winners. The researchers then measured how much the near winners spent once they entered them all. They spent a lot more than those who clearly lost or those who won. And this
你又不会吃钱。那是为了——唾液分泌已被证明是欲望的一种度量。所以当你渴望某样东西时，你分泌的唾液就更多。在第二个实验中，研究人员在购物中心外面给人们发彩票。同样，这个想法是有些人会赢，有些人会输，有些人会成为接近赢家。然后研究人员测量了那些接近赢家的人进入商场后花了多少钱。他们比那些明显——接近赢家的人花得更多。然后研究人员测量了那些接近赢家的人进入商场后花了多少钱。他们比那些明显输了的人或赢了的人花得更多。而这
was like a really cool thing because from a marketing perspective, marketers think that winning will actually make them spend more, but this was just the other way around. Monica says the experience of nearly winning something can motivate people of all ages. I'm wondering if it has implications for things like parenting as well and management of people in a workforce. I mean, so if you're trying to get your kid to practice the piano, for example, in some ways, sort of not getting the sticker from the teacher every week might actually be better than reliably getting the sticker every single week. Right, absolutely. If you get it each day every day, you are totally sissy at it.
真的是一件很酷的事情，因为从营销的角度来看，营销人员认为赢了实际上会让他们花更多钱，但事实恰恰相反。莫妮卡说，差点赢得某些东西的经历可以激励所有年龄段的人。我在想，这是否也对诸如育儿以及职场人员管理等方面有所启示。我的意思是，如果你想让你的孩子练习钢琴，举个例子，在某种程度上，每周拿不到老师的贴纸，实际上可能比每次每周都可靠地拿到贴纸要好。是的，绝对的。如果你每天都拿到，你就会对它完全厌烦。
You want to build that thing in that, hey, you're almost there. You're just there, but not quite there. That's Monica Wadwa, professor of marketing at the NCAD Business School in Singapore. After this break, we're going to be joined by my friend Daniel Pink for another round of Stop-Wat Science. Back now for another round of Stop-Wat Science, I'm Shankar Vidantanthan.
你想树立这样一种信念，即，嘿，你快成功了。你就在那里，但又差那么一点点。这位是莫妮卡·瓦德瓦，新加坡欧洲工商管理学院市场营销学教授。休息过后，我的朋友丹尼尔·平克将加入我们，进行新一轮的“秒表科学”。欢迎回到新一轮的“秒表科学”，我是香卡·维丹坦塔姆。
And I'm Daniel Pink. Dan is our senior Stopwatch science correspondent. He's also the author of several books about human behavior. On Stopwatch Science, Dan and I give one another 60 seconds to summarize interesting social science research. I'll run a stopwatch as Dan speaks, and here's the buzzer he's going to hear if he exceeds his time. That's not the sound of a dinner gong, Dan. That's
我是丹尼尔·平克。丹是我们的资深“秒表科学”记者。他也是几本关于人类行为的书籍的作者。在“秒表科学”节目中，丹和我互相给对方60秒的时间来总结有趣的社会科学研究。当丹说话时，我会按动秒表，如果他超时，他将听到以下蜂鸣器声。丹，那可不是晚宴锣的声音。那是
a sound that says you need to stop. That's like a Chuck Baris gong show gong. You're off to stage. What's the sound of my buzzer, Dan? You're going to hear this sound right here. A little bit of a loony tune sounds appropriate for this segment. All right. That is a profoundly irritating sound, and I'm going to try and make sure I don't get to hear it. Our topic today is about Neil Wins. As you just heard, Monica Wadba found that getting close to a win can boost your motivation and drive. Dan and I are going to look at several other factors right now. Dan, if you're ready, your first 60 seconds starts now. Well, those of us who've taken Psychology 101, probably remember the famous study that showed when a rat gets closer to food, the rat moves faster. Okay, so this is a study from the Journal
一个告诉你需要停止的声音。这就像查克·巴里斯《轰动一时》节目里的锣声。你得下台了。丹，我的蜂鸣器是什么声音？你会听到这个声音。一段有点像“乐一通”的声音，很适合这个环节。好吧。那是一个极其烦人的声音，我会尽量确保自己不会听到它。我们今天的主题是关于“差点赢”。正如你刚刚听到的，莫妮卡·瓦德瓦发现，接近胜利可以增强你的动机和驱动力。丹和我现在将探讨其他几个因素。丹，如果你准备好了，你的前60秒现在开始。嗯，我们这些学过心理学101的人，可能还记得那个著名的研究：当老鼠接近食物时，老鼠移动得更快。好吧，所以这是一项来自《实验社会科学杂志》的研究
of Experimental Social Psychology asking the important question, what if someone else is the rat and something else is the food? So what they did is they looked at charities. When do we make gifts to charity? And they looked at donations to Kiva,va the online charity and they found not surprisingly that as people got closer to their stated goal giving went dramatically up then they also did a study where they simulated a
提出了一个重要的问题：如果另一个人是老鼠，而其他东西是食物呢？所以他们做的是研究慈善机构。我们什么时候向慈善机构捐款？他们研究了对Kiva（在线慈善机构Kiva）的捐款，不出所料地发现，当人们接近他们既定的目标时，捐款急剧上升；然后他们还做了一项研究，模拟了一个
kid named shea and they said shea has to candy bars to sell to hit her quota verses thirty to candy bars to sell to hit a quota not surprisingly they gave more sell to hit a quota. Not surprisingly, they gave more money when Sheila was only two away. And this goes to really why do people give to charity? Some of it's to be altruistic and relieve negative emotions, but it's also so they can feel effective. And that's what near wins do. All right, great. I hope my gong was effective. It certainly got down to stop speaking. I think
名叫谢拉的孩子，他们说谢拉有两根棒棒糖要卖以完成配额，相对的有三十根棒棒糖要卖以完成配额，不出所料，他们给出了更多——要卖以完成配额。不出所料，当谢拉只差两个就能完成时，他们捐了更多的钱。这真正解释了人们为什么向慈善机构捐款？一部分是为了利他并缓解负面情绪，但也是为了让他们自己觉得有成效。这就是“差点赢”所起的作用。好吧，太棒了。我希望我的锣声起作用了。它确实让丹停止说话了。我认为
this is fascinating though, Dan, because of course we all feel that as we get closer to the goal, it's actually attainable. Right. What I think was interesting about this is that someone else was actually pursuing the goal. What you were doing is you were giving a little bit of a lift and you're more likely to give that person some assistance when that person is nearing the goal. Yeah, and public radio stations do this all the time instead of saying our goal is two million dollars. They say our goal for this segment is sixty thousand dollars because it makes people feel that they can actually get to that goal that's more attainable well our goal for this segment is to see if Sean car can do his study in sixty seconds and his time starts right now all right so if you want to know how to motivate people it's very important to ask where they are in the process of reaching their goal are they just starting out or are they nearly on their way to the goal? Are they nearly at the win? Very much like you're just saying that. CG Wong at the University of Texas at Austin recently published a paper
这很迷人，丹，因为当然我们都觉得当我们离目标更近时，它实际上是可以达到的。没错。我认为这有趣的地方在于，实际上是另一个人在追求目标。你在做的是给予一点支持，当那个人接近目标时，你更有可能向那个人提供一些帮助。是的，公共广播电台一直在这样做，他们不说我们的目标是两00万美元。他们说我们这个环节的目标是六万美元，因为这让人觉得他们真的能实现这个目标，那更容易达到。好吧，我们这个环节的目标是看看香卡能否在60秒内完成他的研究，他的计时现在开始。好的，所以如果你想知道如何激励人们，最重要的是问他们在实现目标的进程中处于什么位置：他们是刚刚开始，还是已经在通往目标的路上？他们是不是快要赢了？这很像你刚才所说的。德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校的CG·王最近在
in the Journal of Personality and Social Psychology that found that where you are in the process makes a big difference in your motivation. When we are in the early stages of a challenge, it's important to have multiple options. If you hear there are six different ways you can give money to a public radio station, you're more likely to stay engaged in the pledge drive. On the other hand, as you get close to the win, having more options turns into a hindrance. In one study, as a blood donation drive started to approach its final stages, people were more likely to be willing to donate blood when they were given a single way to do so, rather than given multiple ways. So in other words, at the early stages of a quest, having lots of options gives us a reason not to lose hope as you approach the win, having lots of options becomes a distraction.
《人格与社会科学杂志》上发表了一篇论文，发现你在进程中所处的位置对你的动机有很大影响。当我们处于挑战的早期阶段时，拥有多种选择是很重要的。如果你听说有六种不同的方式可以向公共广播电台捐款，你更有可能继续参与认捐活动。另一方面，当你接近胜利时，拥有更多的选择反而会成为一种阻碍。在一项研究中，随着献血活动开始接近尾声阶段，当人们只有一种捐血方式，而不是有多种方式时，他们更愿意捐血。换句话说，在探索的早期阶段，有很多选择给了我们不失去希望的理由；而当你接近胜利时，有很多选择就会变成一种干扰。
Oh, you were out of options, but you came in right on time. That's interesting. We can think of it as kind of a motivational funnel. You start wide, then you get closer and closer, you go narrow. I love the funnel idea, Dan has reached the narrow end of his funnel, because his next 60 seconds starts right now. Okay, so we've talked a lot about the positive elements of near wins. Let's talk about the dark side of near wins, and this is a study from the journal Neuron, using two of my all-time favorite technologies,
哦，你的选择用完了，但你正好准时进来了。这很有趣。我们可以把它看作是一种动机漏斗。你从宽口开始，然后越来越近，变得狭窄。我喜欢漏斗这个主意，丹已经走到了他漏斗的窄端，因为他的下一个60秒现在开始。好吧，所以我们讨论了很多关于“差点赢”的积极因素。让我们谈谈“差点赢”的黑暗面，这是一项来自《神经元》杂志的研究，使用了我历来最喜欢的两种技术，
FMRIs, functional magnetic resonance images, and slot machines. And here's what they did. They put a bunch of participants in these FMRIs and had them play slot machines, but the slot machines, of course, were rigged, as all slot machines are, I guess. Actually. Sometimes the participants won, and a certain region of their brain was activated, but then they had them lose, just by a hair. And you know what what the exact same region
功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）和老虎机。他们是这样做的：他们把一群参与者放进这些fMRI里，让他们玩老虎机，但老虎机当然是被操纵的，我想所有老虎机都是这样。实际上。有时参与者赢了，他们大脑的某个区域被激活了，但接着让他们仅仅以微弱差距输掉。你知道吗，完全相同的区域
was activated what so what happened is when they won their brain said let's play again and then when they lost they said let's play again so this is the dark side of of near winds there almost have an addictive quality which is why you should stay at a vagus unless you bring your fm r i i love the study then because actually it measures so nicely with what monica wadwa was talking about, which is the effect of coming very close to a win is actually very similar in the brain to actually winning. Yes, and you're very close to winning here, because you have one minute for your next study and it starts now. Alright, so this is one of my favorite studies on the science of motivation.
也被激活了。所以发生的事情是，当他们赢了，他们的大脑说“再玩一次”；而当他们输了，他们说“再玩一次”。所以这是“差点赢”的黑暗面。它们几乎具有某种成瘾性，这就是为什么你应该远离拉斯维加斯，除非你随身带上fMRI。丹，我喜欢这项研究，因为它实际上与莫妮卡·瓦德瓦所谈论的内容非常契合，即非常接近胜利的效果在大脑中实际上与真正获胜非常相似。是的，你在这里也快要赢了，因为你的下一项研究有一分钟时间，现在开始。好的，这是我关于动机科学最喜欢的的研究之一。
I talked about it with Steven Sk keep on morning edition some months ago max Austin Elliott the University of Wisconsin-Malwaki along with David Luna and Torsten Ringberg they recently analyzed how movement can affect motivation and they find that telling or showing people they are moving upward or downward can impair or increase their driving motivation in one experiment the researchers asked people to imagine riding up 20 floors in an elevator or riding down 20 floors in an elevator.
几个月前，我在《早安》节目中与史蒂芬·斯基平讨论过这个问题。威斯康星大学密尔沃基分校的马克斯·奥斯汀·埃利奥特（Max Austin-Elliott）以及大卫·卢纳（David Luna）和托尔森·林伯格（Torsten Ringberg）最近分析了运动如何影响动机，他们发现告诉或展示人们他们是在向上移动还是向下移动，会削弱或增强他们的驱动力和动机。在一个实验中，研究人员让人们想象坐电梯上20层楼或坐电梯下20层楼。
The volunteers had then given math puzzles to solve in three minutes. And what the researchers find is that the volunteers who imagine going down, solved more math problems than volunteers who imagine going upward. And the difference wasn't trivial, it was a 30% difference. The researchers think this is happening because
然后，志愿者被要求在三分钟内解决数学谜题。研究人员发现，想象向下的志愿者比想象向上的志愿者解决了更多的数学问题。而且这种差异并非微不足道，这是一个30%的差异。研究人员认为之所以发生这种情况是因为
as you move upward, your self-esteem gets boosted and when you feel better about yourself, you say, eh, who cares? Why don't you solve math problems? I feel pretty good already. So this study suggests, Dan, that the next time you and I sit down to record stopwatch science, instead of sitting on the fourth floor of NPR, we're going to go to the basement. I'm in, I'm in, absolutely, absolutely fascinating and of course neither one of us has an overconfidence problem so that should be fair. Absolutely, I'm sure it doesn't affect us whatsoever but I'm hearing our producers say they're going to build a new basement in the studio.
随着你向上移动，你的自尊心会得到提升，当你对自己的感觉更好时，你会说：“呃，谁在乎呢？为什么还要解数学题？我已经感觉挺好了。”所以这项研究表明，丹，下次你和我坐下来录制“秒表科学”时，我们不要坐在NPR的四楼，我们要去地下室。我加入，我加入，绝对的，绝对迷人，当然我们两个都没有过度自信的问题，所以这应该很公平。绝对的，我确信这丝毫不影响我们，但我听到我们的制作人说他们要在工作室里建一个新的地下室。
Alright, this has been another round to stop what science, I'm Shankar Vidantantham. And I'm Daniel Pink. After this break I have a special guest joining me in the studio, country music singer Casey Musgraves. Stay with us. Now we're going to introduce you to a new segment that we're calling Mad Scientist. Our first victim, country music singer, Kasey Musgraves. Kasey, thanks for joining me on The Hidden Brain. Thank you. Kasey was just upstairs at NPR to perform a tiny desk concert.
好的，这又是新一轮的“秒表科学”，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。我是丹尼尔·平克。休息过后，我有一位特别的嘉宾加入我的工作室，乡村音乐歌手凯茜·马斯格雷夫斯。请继续收听。现在我们将向你介绍一个我们称之为“科学怪人”的新环节。我们的第一个受害者，乡村音乐歌手，凯茜·马斯格雷夫斯。凯茜，谢谢你加入我的《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你。凯茜刚才在NPR楼上进行了“微型桌面音乐会”的表演。
A new album is called Pageant Material. I'm pageant material. I'm always higher than my hair. And it ain't that I don't care about world peace But I don't see how I can fix it in a swimsuit on stage As I listen to the album Casey, I told myself there is no possible way anyone has done social science research that looks at the connection between world peace and wearing a swimsuit on a stage
她的新专辑叫《选美标准》。我是选美标准。我的发型总是比头发还高。并不是我不关心世界和平，只是我不知道如何在舞台上穿着泳衣解决它。当我听这张专辑时，凯茜，我告诉自己，绝对不可能有人做过社会科学研究来探讨世界和平与在舞台上穿泳衣之间的联系
and wouldn't you know it, I was wrong. So it turns out I came by work out of Arizona State University that looks at how beauty pageant winners go on to win political office. So between 2000 and 2010, something like 12% of all female governors elected in the United States were former beauty pageant contestants. And among them of course, we have Sarah Pailin, former governor of Alaska, beauty pageant contestant. If John McCain had been elected president, she would be vice president today in all
你猜怎么着，我猜错了。原来我找到了一项亚利桑那州立大学的研究，探讨了选美冠军后来是如何赢得政治职位的。所以在2000年到2010年之间，美国当选的所有女性州长中大约有12%是前选美选手。当然，在她们之中，我们有萨拉·佩林，阿拉斯加前州长，选美选手。如果约翰·麦凯恩当选总统，她很有可能在今天成为副总统。
likelihood. She might have been the front runner for president in 2016. And in 2017, she might have had her finger on the big red nuclear button. Who knows? So, you tell me, Casey, can wearing a swimsuit on a stage have anything to do with the world peace? Maybe it's to do with the brain in the swimsuit. I don't know Where did the idea for pageant material come from?
她本可能成为2016年总统竞选的领跑者。而在2017年，她本可能把手指放在那个红色核按钮上。谁知道呢？所以，你告诉我，凯茜，在舞台上穿泳衣和世界和平有什么关系吗？也许这跟泳衣里的大脑有关。我不知道。“选美标准”这个灵感是从哪里来的？
so Pageant material was written with two friends of mine Luke layered and Shane McNelly and Shane is from the southeast from Texas as am I. So we both kind of grew up in this area where that was a total normal thing, you know. That was a thing girls really wanted to do and he had this title. He said, I really want to write a song called Pageant Material and I just thought I can totally get behind that. I mean it's just like a light-hearted song, just kind of poking fun at myself for not being, you know, maybe up to like industry pageant standards and sometimes in the music industry, there's expectations for women
所以《选美标准》是我和我的两个朋友卢克·莱尔德（Luke Laird）和肖恩·麦克纳利（Shane McNally）一起写的，肖恩来自东南部，德克萨斯州，我也是。所以我们俩都在这样一个地方长大，在那里这是一件完全正常的事情，你知道的。那是女孩们真的很想做的一件事，他想出了这个标题。他说，我真的很想写一首歌叫《选美标准》，我当时想，我完全支持这一点。我的意思是，这就像是一首轻松的歌，有点取笑自己，因为我可能没有达到行业选美标准，有时在音乐行业中，对女性会有一些期望
to maybe act a certain way and I've found myself in certain situations where I don't come up to par with some of those things. And so when that happens, do you feel critical about yourself or do you say look these as silly social norms, I'm glad I'm actually not following them. The latter, for sure. I mean, you know, I think there's always going to be people that are looking to find something wrong with what you're doing or, you know, picking them apart, but I think it's always best just to be yourself. And if that means, you know, you're not smiling at a certain point or this or that, you know, it's if it's what you're feeling, you know,
也许要表现得某种特定方式，我发现自己在某些情况下没有达到其中一些标准。所以当这种情况发生时，你会对自我感到批判，还是会认为这些是愚蠢的社会规范，并庆幸自己其实没有遵循它们？绝对是后者。我的意思是，你知道的，我认为总会有人试图找出你所做事情的不对之处，或者对你挑毛病，但我认为最好还是做你自己。如果这意味着，你知道的，你在某个时刻没有笑或者诸如此类，你知道的，如果是你内心的感受，你知道的，
just a certain extent, I think you should do it. Alright, so that's a great segue into our game. And so I'm gonna tell you how we play mad scientist. Social scientists are constantly coming up with crazy studies and experiments. So on mad scientist, I'm gonna tell you about a piece of social science research and you put on your imaginary lab coat
在某种程度上，我认为你应该那样做。好的，这完美地过渡到了我们的游戏。所以我要告诉你我们是怎么玩“科学怪人”的。社会学家经常想出一些疯狂的研究和实验。所以在“科学怪人”环节，我要告诉你一项社会科学研究，而你要穿上你想象中的实验白大褂，
and try and deduce what the research experiment discovered. Does that sound like a plan? Does my lab coat have rhinestones on it? Yeah. It does. Since it's fictitious, it does. Okay. I think you get to pick the kind of lab coat you want.
并试着推断出研究实验发现了什么。听起来像个计划吗？我的实验白大褂上有水钻吗？有的。既然它是虚构的，它就有的。好的。我想你可以挑选你想要的实验白大褂类型。
Great. So yours definitely has rhinestones. Perfect. So when listening to your title song, Pageant Material, I was struck by a line in the song that talks about how you feel about being run or up. God bless the girls who smile and hug when they're called out as you runnin' up on TV. I wish I could, but I just came. Where it's my own, it's my only, but I'm feeling.
太好了。所以你的绝对有水钻。完美。所以在听你的同名歌曲《选美标准》时，我被歌里的一句歌词所打动，它谈到了你对获得亚军的感受。上帝保佑那些在电视上被叫到名字获得亚军时微笑和拥抱的女孩们。我希望我也能，但我只是觉得。
Alright, so here's the experiment. Many years ago, Thomas Gilevich, who is a psychologist at Cornell University, he and his colleagues collected videotape of all the silver and bronze metal winners at the 1992 Barcelona Olympics. All right, so the video clips showed the immediate reactions, the first reactions when athletes discovered they had won either silver or bronze. Now here's the question and I want you to think it through aloud. We all know that winning silver is better than winning bronze, coming in second is better
好的，实验是这样的。多年前，康奈尔大学的心理学家托马斯·吉洛维奇（Thomas Gilovich）和他的同事收集了1992年巴塞罗那奥运会上所有银牌和铜牌得主的录像带。好的，所以视频剪辑显示了运动员们发现自己赢得银牌或铜牌时的即时反应，第一反应。现在的问题是，我希望你大声思考出来。我们都知道赢得银牌比赢得铜牌好，得第二名比得第三名好。当吉洛维奇和他的同事们
than coming in third. When Gillovich and his colleagues Examine the videos. Do you think they found that the silver medal winners looked happier than the bronze medal winners? Or did they find that the bronze medal winners looked happier than the silver medal winners? Can I ask you questions you certainly can where's the gold winner? The gold winner is off jumping gold winner in this. The gold winner is off jumping exuberantly. So he's already been announced. Yes, he or she has been announced and you know he's jumping up and down. But this experiment is only looking at silver and bronze metal
检查视频时。你认为他们发现银牌得主看起来比铜牌得主更高兴吗？还是他们发现铜牌得主看起来比银牌得主更高兴？我可以问你问题吗？当然可以。金牌得主在哪儿？金牌得主在一边兴奋地跳跃。金牌得主在这其中吗？金牌得主在一边兴奋地跳跃。所以他已经宣布了。是的，他或她已经被宣布了，而且你知道他在上蹦下跳的。但这个实验只观察银牌和铜牌得主。
winners. Well, I can't help but feel like this is a massive trick. No, but I would say obviously silver because it's a higher rank, but maybe even knowing that you got bronze and you're not totally out. Oh man, this is a hard one. Alright, so I'm going to give you a clue. The clue has to do with who you're comparing yourself against, that our happiness levels and our satisfaction with what we get in life is often not just tied to what we have, but it's often tied in comparison to what other people have. So who does a silver medal winner compare himself for herself to and who does a bronze medal compare himself for herself to and that's the clue to the answer.
嗯，我忍不住觉得这是一个巨大的陷阱。不，但我会说显然是银牌，因为它的排名更高，但也许甚至知道你得了铜牌，而你并没有完全出局。哦天哪，这是一个难题。好的，所以我要给你一个线索。线索与你将自己与谁进行比较有关，我们的幸福水平以及对我们在生活中得到的东西的满意度往往不仅与我们拥有什么有关，而且往往与我们与其他人拥有的东西进行比较有关。那么，银牌得主将自己与谁作比较，铜牌得主将自己与谁作比较，这就是答案的线索。
Oh, yeah. So maybe there's a bigger letdown with silver comparing themselves to the ultimate winner. But there's more joy in a bronze winner knowing that they're not a loser at all. So that's your answer? Yes. Casey Mustraves, you are correct. Yes. You have one match I do.
哦，是的。所以也许银牌得主与最终的赢家相比会有更大的失落感。但铜牌得主知道自己根本不是失败者，会有更多的喜悦。所以这就是你的答案？是的。凯茜·马斯格雷夫斯，你答对了。是的。你猜对了一个。
Can I keep my lab code? I think you have to return the lab code. NPR holds on to all the rhinestone lab codes. I'm afraid it's just company policy. I'm wondering if this actually tells you anything about your own life. The idea that when you compare yourself, who you're comparing yourself to actually determines how happy you're going to be, and it makes no sense that bronze medal winners would compare themselves against people who were the total losers and therefore felt happy. And the silver medal winners compared themselves to the gold and they felt unhappy, but that's exactly
我可以保留我的实验白大褂吗？我想你得把实验白大褂还回来。NPR保留所有带水钻的实验白大褂。恐怕这只是公司政策。我想知道这是否实际上告诉你关于你自己的生活的一些事情。当你将自己进行比较时，你将自己与谁进行比较实际上决定了你将有多幸福，铜牌得主会把自己与彻底的失败者进行比较并因此感到快乐，这似乎毫无道理。而银牌得主将自己与金牌得主进行比较，他们感到不快乐，但这正是
what Gilo Vich and his colleagues found. So crazy. I mean, I can totally see that. I heard a quote recently and I think it was, I'm going to get this wrong, but comparison is the ultimate thief of joy. Yes. Something like that. Because there are always going to be people who have more than you. And they'll always be people who have less than you. And so you'd constantly go through life comparing ourselves to all these people and then feeling these silly aspects of happiness and Yes, so avoid when it's like if you could just look at yourself instead you might come away way more happy. Wonderful. That's Casey Musgraves. Her new album is called Pageant Material.
吉洛维奇和他的同事们所发现的。太疯狂了。我的意思是，我完全能理解。我最近听到了一句名言，我想是——我可能会记错，但比较是快乐的终极小偷。是的。差不多是这样。因为总会有人比你拥有更多。也总会有人比你拥有更少。所以我们不断地经历生活，将自己与所有人进行比较，然后感受到这些愚蠢的幸福方面，是的。所以避免这样做，就像如果你只看看你自己，你可能会收获更多的快乐。太棒了。这就是凯茜·马斯格雷夫斯。她的新专辑叫《选美标准》。
Casey, thank you for playing Mad Scientist with me on the Hidden Brain. Thanks for the challenge. To hear more Casey Musgraves, check out her tiny desk concert at NPR Music. For more Hidden Brain, join us on Facebook and Twitter and listen to my NPR stories on your local public radio station. The Hidden Brain podcast is produced by Cara McGurk-Allison and Maggie Pennman, special thanks this week to Chris Benderrev, Bob Boylin and Jacob Gans. I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR.
凯茜，谢谢你和我一起在《隐藏的大脑》中玩“科学怪人”。谢谢你的挑战。想听更多凯茜·马斯格雷夫斯的音乐，请查看她在NPR音乐的微型桌面音乐会。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》内容，请在Facebook和Twitter上加入我们，并在你当地的公共广播电台收听我的NPR故事。《隐藏的大脑》播客由卡拉·麦格克-艾利森（Cara McGurk-Allison）和玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Pennman）制作，本周特别感谢克里斯·本德雷夫（Chris Benderrev）、鲍勃·博伊林（Bob Boylin）和雅各布·甘斯（Jacob Gans）。我是香卡·维丹坦姆，这里是NPR。
and Jacob Gans. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和雅各布·甘斯。我是香卡·维丹坦姆，这里是NPR。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。